did you get funding in the very
beginning and then started honing the
story or did you reach out to the actors
first how did that all work so when I
was in school so I did like i did a
degree like a college degree and then
after that i went to this place in
canada called the canadian film center
and it's like our version of the AFI
basically so I when I was writing it
there as well this script and your they
give you the means to like make a little
short so I made a little short about it
as well that no one will ever see
hopefully ever that's terrible actually
it's alright but so I I did that and
then with that short I approached a
producer in in Toronto that I was
interested in that I had actually worked
with as an actress who was doing really
really interesting work and then yeah
and then we went to the funders with our
collective experiences that short and an
outline and then they give us a little
bit of money to write the first draft
and then once we were in that once we
had the first draft then we actually got
like a little more substantial money for
sort of each subsequent draft so yeah I
mean Canada's really great that way
because we have a government system set
up to support the arts and if you can
get into that system it's also like
highly debated system by multiple
filmmakers as you can understand who are
living in Canada because you know if you
don't get funding it you're sort of left
out but if you end up being a part of
that that system then you can you know
you can could make an okay living for I
mean you are getting yeah there they
acknowledge that you know you have to
take time off of your like teaching job
or your you know your side projects or
whatever to concentrate on the script so
there there is that ability yeah
progressive in Yahweh's yeah absolutely
what they do that in Europe as well I
mean America's is you know they work at
the capitalistic society here so and not
you know that works a lot for film as
well so there's a lot of problems in the
Canadian system but but there is that
kind of belief that there's like true
value in culture in
porting you know arts described
you